pictures of the prime minister there he
is boris johnson
joined with sakir stama
carrying bouquets of flowers they are
walking up the road
they are just walking past
belfair's methodist church
pausing there for a moment
this is where
sir david was holding his
surgery yesterday
when he was
stabbed
and killed
who's that is that pretty tough pretty
pretty there you can see the home
secretary
pretty patel also holding a bouquet of
flowers and pausing
outside the church and the speaker of
the house of commons lindsey hoyle who
was so
vocal yesterday and eloquent in his
praise
of sir david and there you see boris
johnson the prime minister he's
laid that
wreath i believe it was or bouquet of
flowers
and the three taking a moment to pause
and reflect on the death
of someone they all knew so well zakir
stama has also laid his
flowers and is now standing with the
prime minister just to give you an idea
of where they're standing there outside
the methodist church belfairs
where sir david amos was yesterday
killed as he held his constituency
surgery
just an average day
for the mp
who served for 40 years
in south
end me see the leader of the opposition
and boris johnson the prime minister but
it gives you a sense of how united
politicians are in their praise
of sir david amos
they committed backbencher
who dedicated
his life to serving the people of his
constituency
as i mentioned the prime minister
boris johnson and sakir stama leader of
the opposition they have just laid a
wreath outside the methodist church
where sir david amos
was murdered
just yesterday less than 24 hours ago
the police were called
1205 just after midday
to reports of an incident at that church
the home secretary pretty patel is also
here
and speaker of the house lindsay hoyle
pretty patel has called for
a review
into security arrangements
of all mps
we've also heard from tobias ellwood
saying that face-to-face meetings should
actually be
halted they should be paused
until that review has finished
but there we have the prime minister
the leader of the opposition standing
together
we just laid flowers
at the site where david english
was murdered yesterday